i
[Música]
ah
y aquí
es una suerte estar aquí hoy en ted x
medellín para hablar sobre el destino en
el año 2000 fue designado como director
general de un hospital que hoy es líder
en colombia y referente en latinoamérica
un hospital que ha alcanzado tales nivel
de calidad que ha obtenido el sello de
la acreditación nacional en salud con
nivel de excelencia y la acreditación
internacional de la joint commission
international en el año 2020 el hospital
cumple 50 años de existencia tiene 3000
empleados y es capaz de resolver
altísimos problemas de complejidad
precisamente en este año 2020 llevamos a
cabo un trasplante de hígado de donante
vivo en una bebé de tan sólo 5 meses de
edad la mama le dio una porción de su
órgano a la bebé
ambas están vivas y gozan de buena salud
el director que se retiraba tenía 35
años de labor y había sido su primer y
único director y ya había llevado al
hospital a ser un referente de servicio
en el país yo contaba con 42 años de
edad y 16 años de trabajo en el hospital
estaba realmente muy emocionado pero
muerto de susto porque no es lo mismo
dirigir
dirigido el día de la ceremonia de la
transmisión de mando todo el mundo me
deseaba buena suerte algunos con nivel
de escepticismo con eso de esperar y ver
para creer cuando llegué a tomar las
primeras decisiones pensé que si
habíamos sido exitosos lo mejor era
seguir con esta orden sigan haciendo lo
mismo eso garantizaría nuestra buena
suerte pero cuán equivocado estaba
pronto afrontamos un problema de
importante magnitud una entidad a la que
le atendíamos un número de pacientes muy
elevados llegó a tener un nivel de
acreencias tal que puso en riesgo la
sostenibilidad y supervivencia del
hospital se nos había acabado la buena
suerte todos esperaban algo de mí
mientras yo no sabía que se nos esperaba
recordé mi infancia había tenido buena
suerte había les han nacido en el seno
de un hogar bien conformado un padre
médico cardiólogo una mamá compositora
colombiana galardonada yo era el segundo
de cinco hijos de un hogar unido
había heredado el don musical y tenía
habilidad para el estudio incluso antes
de los 2 años de edad había superado un
cuadro de convulsiones febriles
incontrolado que había llevado a mi
abuelo materno un médico pediatra a que
le dijera a mi madre rece por él porque
de ésta no sale pero cuando llegue a la
adolescencia volvía a cambiar mi suerte
no era atractivo no tenía fortaleza
física era malo para los deportes de
equipo y era además tímido en los
equipos juveniles en que jugaba todo el
mundo sabía cuál era la suerte que se
les esperaba entonces pensé que suerte
buena o mala es lo que nos da la vida y
qué destino es aquello que nos labramos
con lo que la vida nos dio de hecho a mí
con esta suerte de rostro no me convino
crear un destino de modelo hubiera sido
una pérdida de tiempo
en suerte no somos simios ni un vegetal
en suerte somos seres humanos en suerte
la vida nos pone y nos trae del exterior
aquello que nos ha de venir pero el
destino no lo logramos desde dentro la
suerte no es algo que elegimos y el
destino si es algo que elegimos y si es
algo que elegimos es porque supone la
libertad pero para poder ser libre hay
que pensar y reflexionar entonces había
que dedicarle más tiempo a eso pero por
sobre todo no a pensar sino a pensar se
pensar es cómo resolver el trinomio
cuadrado perfecto además de al cuadrado
que es igual al cuadrado más 2 sabe más
de al cuadrado yo también me lo sé por
ejemplo con manzanas y naranjas manzana
más naranja al cuadrado es igual a
manzana al cuadrado más dos veces
manzana naranja más naranja al cuadrado
y les voy a contar un secreto a mí el
trinomio ni me ha cambiado la suerte ni
me ha modificado el destino y entonces
si el destino lo tenemos que pensar yo
tuve la buena suerte de tener más tiempo
para pensar
con tanta suerte de problemas que sobre
venían en el hospital me sobrevino un
insomnio y entonces ya que no podía
dormir me dediqué a soñar los libros de
psicología antropología filosofía
sociología se volvieron unos compañeros
porque ellos me permitían profundizar el
ser humano
dos de ellos marcaron mi vida porque
tienen que ver con el cuidado de sí el
cuidado de los demás y el cuidado de
nuestro planeta se llaman el cuidado
necesario y el cuidado esencial de
leonardo boff también quiero contarles
que tuve la buena suerte con algunos de
esos libros porque porque me ayudaron a
combatir el insomnio pero nuevamente
pensé que suerte y destino son bien
diferentes el destino tiene que ver con
el sentido de futuro la suerte es lo
efímero y lo circunstancial el el
destino es lo que queremos que haga
presencia y permanezca la suerte es la
vida el destino lo que queremos hacer
con la vida la suerte especialmente la
buena es algo que se desea
en cambio el destino es algo que se
desea pero también que se decide para
avanzar en lo que
el destino implica hacer lo que queremos
que es muy distinto que hacer lo que a
uno le viene en gana hacer lo que a uno
le viene en gana es quedar sometido a
los impulsos y caprichos y seguir por
mal camino de hecho a mí muchas veces me
venía en gana no tener que resolver
tantos problemas como los que atraía el
hospital y pensando en esto de que el
destino era el sentido de futuro pensé
que mi cargo era director y perca y para
qué está un director para dirigir y en
pos de que de una dirección y un
director brilla por su orquesta y
encontré que lo que había que hacer era
inspirar a un grupo humano en torno a un
propósito y de un hospital que pudiera
servir con razón dijo michael hammer el
padre de la reingeniería y rediseño de
procesos el secreto del éxito no es
prever el futuro sino crear una
organización que prospere en un futuro
que no puede ser previsto pero si
estamos hablando de un futuro de ese
destino que creemos que queremos mejorar
es porque vamos hacia un mundo mejor y
entonces pensé que si me pusieran a
elegir entre
el primero de los mediocres o estar de
último en la lista de los mejores
me voy de último en la lista de los
mejores no quisiera ser recordado por
haber sido un perfecto mediocre pero
cuando uno se compara con los mejores
necesita humildad y valentía porque se
le ven todos los defectos y eso
literalmente me pasó hace unos pocos
años estaba en colombia filmando un
actor muy reconocido en el mundo tom
cruise
al finalizar la grabación tres personas
que trabajaban con él incluyendo su
doble se regresaron en un avioneta hubo
un accidente aéreo dos de ellos
perecieron y uno fue llevado muy mal
herido y en condición crítica a
urgencias del hospital se le salvó la
vida pero esa no es la historia la
historia es que eso despertó la
curiosidad que se hiciera verdad que el
doble de tom cruise estaba en el
hospital y que sería verdad que tom
cruise fue a visitar a su doble y
algunos me preguntaron y te viste con
tom cruise claro y todavía más la
curiosidad y te tomaste una foto con tom
cruise y les dije sí pero ahora estoy en
un problema y me dijo cuál y si es que
ya no se sabe cuál
está un cruz
entonces estamos hablando de un destino
para un mundo mejor
nuevamente el contraste de suerte y
destino suerte se esperar a que las
cosas pasen destino hacer que las cosas
pasen y eso exige un manejo del tiempo
muy diferente y aprendí que podemos
manejar el tiempo de tres maneras el
tiempo de arreglo el tiempo de progreso
y el tiempo de la persona social o
tiempo de la ética tiempo de arreglo es
que vivir genera un gasto y entonces
tenemos que invertir tiempo en dormir
alimentarnos en un hospital y limpiar
las áreas ordenar el instrumental y
aprendí también que era muy sensato no
dañar aquello que funcionaba porque si
no nos teníamos que detener a arreglarlo
de ahí la palabra reparar y si antes no
me venía en gana que vivieran los
problemas ahora salir a buscarlos
comprendí que mi oficina era en mi mente
mis ojos mi corazón mis pies no era una
oficina atractiva pero funcionaba y
retomando el uso del tiempo ese tiempo
de progreso que es el segundo de los
tiempos que tiene que ver con conocer
las cosas y aprenderlas
dejar con destreza y eso nos hacía más
eficientes y más eficaces es decir
ahorramos tiempo y si ahorramos tiempo
porque no teníamos que arreglar tanto y
éramos más eficientes podíamos dedicar
el tiempo a lo más importante a ese
tiempo de transformación personal y
social a crear relaciones de confianza y
de cooperación y entonces en ese labrar
el destino y no esperar la suerte en el
hospital aprendí que había que dirigir a
este grupo humano bien intencionado en
torno de tres propósitos a tener un
cuidado compasivo a servir con
excelencia científica y técnica ya que
el hospital pudiera mejorar la comunidad
a la cual servimos salí a buscar
muchísimas historias para decirle a la
gente que cada uno estaba conectado con
el destino del hospital y entonces en
algún momento se me ocurrió contar esas
historias portando los uniformes de cada
una de las áreas del hospital realmente
todos nos conmovimos y nos unimos en
torno a ese propósito
yo he tenido buena suerte buscando el
destino he tenido la suerte de no ser
atractivo entonces uno nunca pierde lo
que nunca tuvo he encontrado que el
destino es lo amplio lo vasto y que hay
que dejar de lado la angustia y el
estrés angustia del latín angustia lo
que está angosto estrés del inglés
stretch lo que está estrecho en suerte
tenemos la vida y en suerte estamos en
este universo un universo que es enorme
que tiene 13 mil 800 millones de años y
que nuestra suerte con relación a ese
tiempo es solo vivir desde el punto de
vista cósmico dos y medio milisegundos
pero eso es tiempo más que suficiente
para transformar mi propia vida y la de
muchos más somos nada en el universo
pero somos todo para alguien que nos
necesita y por eso yo los invito a
caminar en ese destino con tres
importantes actitudes la mente debe ser
flexible para poder aprender el corazón
debe ser tierno para poder actuar con
bondad y la voluntad tiene que ser
férrea
para poder superar los obstáculos y
dificultades de la vida yo los invito a
que no dejemos nuestra vida en manos de
la suerte sino que caminemos en pos de
un destino de un mundo mejor y que
disfrutemos en ese camino palabra que
viene del latín sacar el fruto yo hoy he
tenido la suerte de estar aquí en ted x
medellín para hablarles de el destino
[Música]